imaginez que vous déambulez dans une
ruelle de toronto le soir puis imaginer
que soudainement des policiers vous
interpelle sans raison apparente
soit c'est pas 4 voitures puis six ou
sept agents si ce qu'a vécu des semaines
colle une cinquantaine de fois en neuf
ans un contrôle aléatoire d'identité
allant même jusqu'à la fouille
corporelle
plus souvent qu'autrement l'histoire se
termine sans arrestation ou
contravention 6 1 fâché indigné tu ne
comprends pas pourquoi la raison ce
qu'on appelle le fichage est une
pratique courante et controversée à
toronto
entre 2008 et 2012 près de deux millions
personnes ont été fichés profilage
racial scandent des groupes
communautaires depuis des semaines la
communauté noire représente 8 % de la
population de toronto mais plus de 25%
des personnes fichées
la contestation populaire a été si forte
que le maire john tory a finalement
changé d'idée il promesse d'abolir la
pratique controversée du fichage pour
rétablir un certain lien de confiance
avec le communauté noire de la ville la
plus cosmopolite du pays
mais ce n'est pas si simple que ça - oui
deux papes les trois fronts le nouveau
chef de police et défend la pratique du
fichage
il soutient que lorsque mener
correctement et non de façon aléatoire
elle permet d'accroître la sécurité
publique en obtenant entre autres des
informations sur des membres de gangs de
rue l'étudiant en droit ni à ses nuits
conteste la légalité du fichage devant
les tribunaux il affirme que la tactique
policière viole la charte canadienne des
droits et libertés
c'est pas que je déteste la police
séparaient des semaines qu elle attend
de voir si le fichage sera abolie et les
données récoltées détruites
sinon avertit-il les policiers
n'arriveront pas à regagner la confiance
de la communauté noire ici philippe
leblanc radio canada toronto